on the edge of Europe a pocket of
pro-russian support
this is transnistria a breakaway region
in eastern Moldova politically
economically and militarily supported by
Moscow
here the hammer and sickle flutters in
the wind as public opinion favors the
east
transnistria and Russia are one
structure and they have to be United
Andre says
the Russian troops here are our
guarantee of safety while they're here
we are safe this young woman adds
under the Gaze of Soviet icons here it's
Ukraine that's been eyed with suspicion
recently accused of plotting to kill
their separatist leader something it
denies
a few miles away in pro-western Moldova
allegiances are very different
local mayor ludmiller says they're
feeling nervous of their neighbors
I believe they have a big base of World
War II weapons and this is our biggest
fear she tells me we hope they won't
come here with their weapons because
Moldova has a small army
Moldova is in the middle of a kind of
political tug of war with the Russians
trying to exploit divisions of the past
and the government here trying to keep
everyone together
Russia's been accused of stirring up
unrest at anti-government protests and
spreading propaganda to weaken Ukraine's
allies
in moldova's capital the UK foreign
secretary came with a message for
support and 10 million pounds to help
fight Russian interference How likely is
it do you think that Moldova could be
Russia's next Target and what's your
message to President Putin well Dave has
been doing all the right things but in
his arrogance Putin has attempted to
punish Moldova for doing those right
things and it is incumbent upon the UK
and our friends and allies across Europe
European continent to support Moldova as
it continues on that Progressive journey
in the right direction
ministers don't expect Russian tanks to
roll across this border anytime soon but
make no mistake they are fighting a war
a battle against disinformation and
disruption aimed at spreading fear and
unrest
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Moldova